y el presidente de Corea del Sur
anunciaron un nuevo acuerdo desde la
casa blanca que tiene como objetivo
disuadir la agresión de Corea del Norte
y la creciente influencia de china en la
región el llamado acuerdo declaración de
Washington es un conjunto de nuevos
pasos para impulsar la cooperación entre
Estados Unidos y Corea del Sur en
materia no solamente de entrenamiento
militar sino también intercambio de
información y de movimientos de activos
estratégicos frente a esta reciente
serie de lanzamientos de misiles de
parte de Corea del Norte El acuerdo
militar También incluye un nuevo
compromiso de Estados Unidos para
desplegar un submarino con armas
nucleares en Corea del Sur por primera
vez desde la década de los 80 sin
embargo funcionarios de la
administración de Joe biden dejaron
claro que el submarino no estará
estacionado de forma permanente que no
hay ningún plan para desplegar armas
nucleares tácticas en la Península de
Corea se trata de extender la disuasión
y esto incluye La amenaza nuclear para
disuadir el uso de Estas armas dijo Joe
biden desde la Casa Blanca